alikum wa rahmatullah have other cat so
guys I'm here in the graveyard and I'm
doing something that we should be all
doing more regularly which is coming to
the graveyards as the professor told us
to do our thinking about death because
this is the reality
death is the reality so Allah Allah
we're all going to end up in this place
and we're all gonna end up dead and
that's something we all need to focus on
think about that is the true
authenticity of the human being when
they think about that which they're
trying to forget about frankly you know
we all try to forget about the fact that
we've got limited days on this earth and
that we're gonna end up under the ground
subhanAllah and one thing that we're
gonna continue is gonna continue is our
deeds yeah the only thing that's gonna
be benefit of benefit to us in that
graveyard is our deeds no material
possession just our deeds and
subhanAllah we're coming close to
Ramadan this might be our very last time
I'm done you know I'm just having say 11
or amadon bring us to Ramadan o Allah
bring us to Ramadan and we have to start
working hard from now because this is
the very beginning it's good to start
strong and we're gonna do so insha'Allah
by giving you an offer with human relief
foundation you'll be working on the
ground in many different countries
including Syria where Ali Dawa is on the
border of the Syrian border in Lebanon
so he's in Lebanon and he's dealing with
as well as the whole team in HRF they're
dealing with you know those people in
camps in that area and we're delivering
food packages to individuals there 60
pounds will will be enough for to feed
one family for the holiday Ramadan so 60
pounds upon imagine how much reward you
can get from 60 pounds and for us here
in the UK for example you guys are
watching this elsewhere in Europe or the
US or somewhere where there's a so
called high economically developed
status of that country then we should be
really really like you know cognizant of
the fact that we have a lot more money
than those individuals we have so much
more privileges than those individuals
we have an obligation therefore to those
individual I feel like Apollo
forgotten about the Syrian people I feel
like somehow I was forgotten about the
the people that have been rejected have
been rejected from their homes and
driven out of their homes from this
because of this war so subhanAllah this
is an opportunity guys let's start
strong that I'm a done let's do what we
need to do because if we don't
subhanAllah will will regret it so hrf
the links gonna be provided in the
bottom of this video you know 60 pounds
a whole families of how that's going to
be so great for us to do you know a lot
of analysis Nora where I'm
terminating for in the who you livable
or hydras that mean that whatever you
give for the sake of Allah he'll bring
it back to you and he's the best of
providers so don't think you're going to
be losing out by giving to charity
Allah will replace it for you and you
have to think about your grave in your
space in that grave because those deeds
that we do now are going to contribute
to our reckoning in that grave so I'm
already gonna fill our cast